bonjour bonjour et bienvenue sur
diagonale tv toujours pour ce
championnat du monde
anand karl scène cette fois nous allons
voir la partie numéro aux deux parties
très intéressante très certainement
puisque la ananda de nouveau les blancs
alors qu'ils viennent avoir deux fois de
suite les noirs dans cette huitième
partie après une septième d'anthologie
et en 22 courses est une des plus
longues du championnat du monde depuis
le début depuis du 5-6
donc la huitième partie à notre panda
les blancs il va rester après celle là
uniquement quatre parties donc un an des
modes et d'un point et c'est bien sûr il
a encore le temps de revenir mais chaque
fois qu'il aura les blancs et bien et va
se poser la question de tenter de
marquer le point puisque après cette
partie il n'aura plus que deux fois la
possibilité avant les blancs à
l'ambition on peut tenter de gagner
aussi avec les noirs mais c'est un peu
plus difficile surtout en championnat du
monde donc là on va voir dans cette
partie ce qui va se passer comment un
homme a essayé de revenir peut-être ou
de tenir le choc suite à la partie
numéro 7 qui était quand même
extrêmement éprouvante mais bon pour les
deux joueurs un pas que pour un an menée
sur ce qu'elle était assez longue et
tendue à nombre de démarre avec des
quatre voilà donc là il varie pas lui
non plus cavaillé 6 c 4 1 le 6 donc là
car scène continue de jouer soit gambie
dame soit ou estonienne comme il a pu
comment on a pu le voir dans le tour
dans le tournoi précédemment cavani 3 et
la d5
voilà donc il revient ici carsen varier
encore une fois il ne joue plus ne
rejoue pas l'ouest indienne ce qui
l'avait fait précédemment il avait joué
b6 et puis après il avait joué faux b4
rappelez-vous échec avec une l'ouest
indienne est donc là c'est plutôt donc
le candidat mir vion gambie dame
qu'avait laissé 3 ea tranquille fosse
est fou et 4 alors rappelez vous cette
variante carsen a déjà joué similaires
le fou en f4 ont tapé sur ces 7 ici et
puis on en avait fait un plan à base de
ces 5 b 4 et puis abandonné les noirs on
essaie de défendre depuis bessec etc
si vous rappeler d'ailleurs c'est la
victoire d'un an donc
une partie très belle donc là est-ce que
carsen va retomber dans ce dans cette
variante on va le voir après petit rock
e3 d'accord donc là on protège ici le
pion donc le roi était là on pouvait
envisager damas quatre échecs dans prend
la menace était plus possible donc cette
façon c'est l'heure de développer ce fou
donc 3 est tout à fait logique regardez
comme c'est harmonieux de jouets 3 une
fois qu'on a sorti le fou voilà on sort
d'avoir le ferons jouer 3 après donc le
foot est comme ça n'est pas enfermé
derrière ses pions en tout cas il faut
développer ces pièces mais pas dans
n'importe quel ordre non plus ces 5
bon voilà c'est terminé il y aura plus
cette variante avec ses 5 pour un accès
sûr puisque ses cinq on est dans l'autre
chose c'est 5 on est sur une variante du
gom vidame symétrique un des cinq ces
cinq c4 des 4 alors là il faut pouvoir
plusieurs façons de traiter cette
position des princes et 5 d'un land
alors ça peut être logique 1 donc je
prends tout de suite le pion c5
bon moi je n'aime pas trop ce coup parce
que c'est en général les blancs qui qui
essaie d'attaquer donc on va essayer de
jouer plutôt que des 3rocs on laisse les
noirs prendre eux mêmes et on se donne
un pion isolé au centre mais comme c'est
la première fois que carcelle lui joue
cette cette ouverture peut-être que
canon n'ose pas tout de suite entré dans
les ventes les plus pointues ça c'est
possible aussi bon peu importe
évidemment c'est jouable je vais pas
dire c'est pas bien faux princier 5 à 3
bon pourquoi pas alors à trois on éviter
un éventuel faux b4 bon c'est une
première chose quoique ce fou a déjà
joué pas mal ça fait une
ce serait trois fois mais surtout on
prépare b4 parce qu'on peut essayer
d'avoir de du jeu à l'aide d'un b 4 c 5
pourquoi pas on peut essayer de jouer
comme ça mais on donnerait dans ce cas
là si on joue b4 ces cinq là trois pions
contre 2 mais on abandonne les pions
saint trop au noir qui le jour où ils
vont de bouger vont en prendre beaucoup
de l'importance qu'avait laissé six
suites n'aurons pas peur de b4
apparemment dame ces deux d'abord voilà
très bien alors à savoir que dans ce
genre de position même si c'est ça peut
paraître surprenant parce que les blancs
ont joué ces quatre ils ont joué à
troyes mais par ya des variantes tournoi
je vous y voilà l'avantagé c'est qu'on
perd pas de temps mais tout de suite la
tour sur la colonne des bons le roi est
à l'air ici sur cette colonne puisque à
tout moment les noirs peuvent échanger
mais on peut jouer arabe et un bon là
c'est au noir de jouer donc tout huit
ont très bien pourquoi pas et là le
grand roque qui peut et faisable mais
alors à la fois c'est très agressif
l'idée c'est que mais pourquoi pas aller
attaquer le roi noir g4 et pour jouer g5
pour perturber ce cavalier aussant est
attaqué le centre puisqu'il ya les pions
lecavalier la tour qui attaquent des 5
et 6 les noirs prennent à angers 4 tour
g1 avec une tour en vis-à-vis du roi ce
qui fait toujours peur mais bon c'est
les sacrifices alors est ce qu'à un an
des prêts à tous grillés dans cette
partie non alors par consigne était la
dernière du match c'est peut-être il se
lancerait dans une attaque de ce type là
avec grand roque voilà c'est ça aussi
est-ce que voilà il est peut-être y
ménage la chèvre et le chou mais ce
qu'il a le temps d'un match en 12
parties est ce qu'on a aussi lorsqu'on a
autant le temps que les anciens matchs
en 24 c'est pas sûr bon alors donc que
là ils jouent au foot j'ai cinq ans le
fonds n'a plus rien à faire sur f4
puisque les attaques sur le pion c'est
cette non
n'existent plus donc ils recyclent sont
fous bon mais il n'a pas fini son
développement elle pas encore sorti son
fouet fin la part auquel auraient pu
faire leurs dents rock ou bon où l'on
sorte un le fou peuvent préparer les
petits qui rejoue le fou bon alors
peut-être peur que le cavalier noir chez
pas se centralise ou que les noirs
jouent h6 je sais pas c'est difficile à
dire bon plein coup son possible ou pas
les commenter tous fawcett bon lait noir
évidemment bon un petit problème ici
quand même parce que il ya menace pu
comprendre qu' on prend et fou prend
cavaliers la dame serait obligé de
reprendre et dans ce cas là le pion des
cinq est perdu ou alors si on veut pas
perdre le tour des cinq
eh bien il faut prendre du plomb j'ai
éteint ce cas là on a la fameuse
histoire que les pions du roi son cas
c'est donc le roi est faible et en
finale en plus c'est une vraie faiblesse
à fos est tranquille on évite ces
problématiques
voilà tour des 1 alors voilà il n'ose
pas de faire ils n'osent pas faire leur
enquête
évidemment si on fait grand roque bon
c'est chaud un grand roque ici bien sûr
on met un visage tourna mais en fait
l'idée des noirs sans doute c'est de
jouer damas 5
et dans ce cas là après grand roque b4
n'est plus possible puisque d'emprunt à
trois échecs et puis après on prend tous
donc à damas 5 et puis bon bain après si
on prend au centre très bien mais ce que
le roi noir lui-même
ceux ci on prend prise prises le fou se
libère donc il est sur une diagonale où
il y aura la dame et puis peut-être sans
doute le roi plus tard puisque le roi on
va pas le laisser en c1 on va le mettre
en bien vous voyez ça peut aller très
vite aussi bien on va pas commenter
parce que c'est quand même tout ça c'est
la théorie mais c'est l'idée c'est que à
la fois on est très agressif mais quand
on est agressif
en général c'est à double tranchant
c'est à dire que l'autre aussi voilà
donc il faut faire attention c'est pas
alors tour d un brin benneteau au centre
mais on évite de mettre le roi disons
sur le côté où s'échouent très bien
damas cinq tranquille donc là maintenant
car scène finit son développement
pourquoi damas m on évite ce vis-à-vis
il y avait quand même des menaces à on
pouvait prendre au centre prendre
d'abord f6 se prendre au centre et puis
c'est gagner un pion par exemple
s'affaiblissent et fortement les noirs
donc là damas s'est conclue le cavalier
en cas de b4 il ya le qe3 qui est faible
donc voilà ce qu alli peut pas bouger on
peut menacer carillo 4 par exemple qu a
lieu quatre le fou cette attaque le fou
g5 lecavalier attaque le cavaly c3 donc
on peut prendre ces trois doubles et les
pions blancs et puis on a cassé la
structure blanche donc fou détroit voilà
donc l'avantagé de fous des 3b c'est que
ça contrôle justement 1,4 donc en cas
des cavaliers clac vous prend enfin pas
fou prend tout de suite attention la
dame ici avec qui a [ __ ] un g5 et la
dame attention à la dame aussi
contrôlant travers ça on les oublie
souvent c'est là donc il faut faire
attention quand même bon mais ya pas de
menaces il ya toujours des contre des
contrecoups ici à mons et harmonieux et
des deux côtés c'est à dire que les
noirs un petit problème pour l'instant
alors poussé meat boy et ses classiques
dans ce camp bidamant général il est
bloqué par son pied on a déjà parlé
souvent on joue b6 pour le jeu m en
baisse est comme on avait vu déjà ou
alors on peut jouer à 6 b5 et puis le
mettre en baisse est aussi voilà en
général donc on le sort plutôt sur 17
sauf si les blancs prennent au centre
avant et dans ce cas là on peut
envisager de sortir par exemple au j4
donc là c'est pas le cas donc h 6 ça y
est les noirs questionne le fou blanc il
faut h quatre canons choisi de ne pas
prendre en existe tout de suite on
aurait pu envisager de prendre 8 6
pourquoi pas avec un affaiblissement au
centre ici mais ce fou à taxer 3 donc il
pourrit apprises pendant ces 3 avec un
doublement des pions blancs et donc un
petit problème quand même deux
structures
puis on prend ces 4
pour qu'arsène il élimine alors
l'avantagé de soucoupe april évident
faux prince et 4 c'est qu'on est dans
une structure symétrique à ces quatre
pions blancs font face à quatre pions
noirs
et puis ses deux pions blancs en face à
deux pions noirs pas même une m deux
couleurs différentes voilà donc c'est
une structure de pions symétrique
or les structures de pions symétrique
implique des parties symétriques et là
le résultat si le résultat d'une partie
symmetrix et en résulte asymétrique
c'est-à-dire la nulle bon écart scène
sera très content de faire nul avec les
noirs puisque s'il pose des problèmes à
un homme quand ils allaient blanc et qui
fait nul avec les noirs et b il va
arriver gagné le championnat du monde et
il mène déjà d'un point à 6 à 6 normal
l'idée et les simples b5 foule s est
terminée j'ai fini mon développement
gély et où j'ai lié les tours ont
regardé comme tous les coups des
champions vise les standards échiquéen
de développement petit rock
ça y est c'est l'heure pour les pour les
blancs à noter que le petit rock aussi
des clous lecavalier ces trois
manquaient toujours qu'ils étaient
toujours cloués des 5
c'est normal c'est fort faut faire
attention ce genre de coups parce que
mais non il ya une dame en c2 donc il ya
un vis-à-vis là quand même avec lequel
elle et ses 6 mais on voit qu'il ya deux
pièces là donc on peut pas en profiter
on devrait donc il faut jouer fou à deux
d'accord là attention parce que les
blancs peuvent menacer les normes ne
font rien on peut menacer les trucs par
exemple fou prendre cavaliers vous prend
et par exemple cavaliers quatre attaques
le fou et en cas de prise il ya une
destruction de la structure et la dame
attaque le cas au lycée 6 voyez donc on
ne faut pas traîner un prêt il faut
attention faut les éviter de laisser des
pieds sans l'air donc bon vous bessette
et naturel voilà c'est réglé allez en
poursuivant le plan de qui simple qui
celui de se développer
hélas un homme montre son sa petite idée
bon ok c'est une petite idée mais on va
voir très vite que c'est pas très
dangereux
foubert
alors là on a une batterie fou dame
classique attaque le long de la
diagonale pour venir faire un échec h7
sur le roi alors évidemment on peut pas
tout de suite puisqu'elle cavaliers m6
et les blancs vont d'abord faire [ __ ]
en france damages cet échec mais sa
menace rien parce que le fou un f6
protégerez g7
on vient f8 damache huit échecs 3e set
et c'est fini la dame est attaqué par la
tour faut qu'elles reviennent à sept et
au final j'ai plus perdu de temps qu
autre chose parce que le roi il sera pas
plus mal
en 7 du moment que le fou de cases
noires disparu donc s'il faut donner le
foot recasement art pour continuer à
attaquer les noirs se protègent
showcases moi donc c'est une menace qui
n'en est pas vraiment une voix là ok
vraiment menace il faudrait que est un
peu plus de choses et notamment faudrait
de menacer par exemple de prendre le
pion g7 sur échec mais pour ça faudrait
pouvoir éliminer le 6 en chassant le fou
bon c'est pas tout de suite le cas on va
voir que anne on a des suites de la
suite dans les idées
le retour à des huit quarts sainement
mais voit qu'il ya un petit peu
d'initiatives faut quand même réagir
biais notamment fini le développement la
seule pièce qui n'avaient pas encore
joué qui ne jouait pas c'était la tour à
regardez encore une fois quand on sait
pas quoi faire et bien c'est simple on
regarde la pièce qui joue bayonne et
celles actives et pouf ton des huit
voilà n'active des pièces ce qui
évidemment si on échange tout bombay les
attaques la taxe va diminuer d'intensité
enfin la taqiyya pas vraiment d'attaqué
mais les noirs effectivement petit
problème avec cette batterie faut faire
attention peut y avoir des trucs
alors faut éviter sous la pression de
s'affaiblir
sans réfléchir fou prend f6 normal c'est
ce qu'on a dit anand continue son idée
damas 7 est possible après foutront m6
voilà je peux faire damage 7 mai que sa
menace rien comme on nous le dira damage
cet échec
roy et suite d'un match 8 3e set et que
fait la dame je suis attaquée par la
tour je suis obligée de revenir en
recettes et le fou contre le tout donc
finalement c'est pas terrible terrible
donc là on en joue sa petite idée c'est
car il ya quatre mois c'est intéressant
puisque le cavalier attaque le fou et 6
là la vraie menace et calais prend
castlerock
et d'un match 7 alors que peuvent jouer
les noirs ici bon il ya plein de coups
possibles par exemple on aurait pu
envisager pour les noirs ben non il n'ya
pas te plaindre on peut aussi bien
accueilli en fait faut faire revenir il
faut revenir recettes fawcett c'est
normal voilà revient recette est bon il
n'y a pas si heureusement qu'à ce
cavalier ce qui maintenant damage 7
serait possible avec matt mai et le
cabba les gènes on peut pas tout avoir
alors la banane aurait pu
tenter quelque chose ici alors bon c'est
pas facile mais un coup comme par
exemple cavalli g3 voilà ça c'était
intéressant qu'alléger 3g deux pièces
ici qui sont quand même du côté roy donc
ils vont il va il veut bon dire ce que
va dire hashtag notamment et h5 qui
contrôlera la casse g7 dont on a vu
qu'elle est importante à cause d'un
match cet échec est aussi la kdf si ce
qui fait que le fou peut pas venir en
défense voilà donc ça c'est possible
alors les noirs la scala pourrait jouer
simplement le coup g6 g6 simplement ça
bloque alors le problème soulevé c'est
possible le problème de ce genre de coup
c'est les blancs en gagner un peu en
quelque sorte puisque ils ont en fait
par leur attaque forcer les noirs à
avancer leurs pions et avancé des pions
c'est toujours un petit avait
affaiblissement de noces que cet
affaiblissement est vraiment grave
il n'a pas l'air mais il pourrait l'être
par exemple maintenant on pourrait
suivre par à 4 suivi de h5 qui paraît
tout à fait logique
mais là les noirs pourrait jouer un coup
intéressant
regardez c'est peut-être pour ça qu'on
n'a pas joué cette variante ces dames à
4 pourquoi parce que j'échange les dames
mais aussi regarder hop je menace avec
le fou d'aller prendre le virage 4 6 4
et comme on a plus de coup de cases
noires pour profiter des cases noires
c'est pas très grave de lâcher
maintenant le foot 15 mois on a fait
bien peu les cases noires mais pas tant
que ça si les petits les foules et blanc
avaient encore leur [ __ ] cases noires
ça serait ça serait très grave parce que
l'aller ça serait vraiment un boulevard
bon mais là c'est pas le cas donc la
dame 1 4 les bleus quasiment obligé de
prendre 1 80
sinon y perdre ils attaquent plus un
pion plus tout voilà puis on prend lyon
prend par exemple est bon bain même si
les pions sont doublés ici le problème
c'est ça c'est faible
voilà ça c'est faible s'il le faut bien
yves 6
ça attaque b2 tout de suite on va on
peut mettre une tour en bus 8 ça attaque
b2 et c les blanchons en défense
donc du coup ça inverse tout
envoyez un c'est quand même dangereux
c'est bien de tenter des coups d'
attaque mais ça peut vite être dangereux
pendant deux prônent pour un peu plus
prudent mais du coup beaucoup moins
ambitieux car les c5
alors qu'avec ses 5 c'est intéressant ça
attaque bessette ça gagne du temps c'est
pas mal c'est une qualité très bien
placés en puissance et cinq caisses que
les noirs peuvent se permettre le luxe
de jouer ce fou par exemple est ce qu'on
aurait pu envisager un coude attentes de
type
phu an à 8 ça marche pas il ya
maintenant il ya damage cet échec on va
le montrer quand même comme cette double
menace
regardez up et maintenant matt donc
évidemment c'est pas possible donc en
jouant qu'avait laissé cinq évidemment
j'ai deux menaces c'est la vallée prend
et aussi matt lorsqu'on peut parer ces
deux menaces
ouf oui on peut car ce n a pas fait de
gaffes fou prend voilà faut prendre et
la regarder d'un match 7 3 et fuites
damas huit échecs 3,7 et bg une pièce de
moins parce que j'ai pas repris la dame
et attaquer donc j'ai rien en fait voilà
j'ai pas d' attaque
il faut que je sorte la dame est un peu
d'initiatives mais j'ai perdu une pièce
donc au final ça va me coûter cher donc
non il faut prendre mais si on prend ces
cinq il ya plus d attaques et la
regarder très jolie de carcelle
liquidation b4 bon alors quand on voit
l'écart at on dit ça y est c'est fini
pourquoi pas parce que les noirs
maintenant on me propose un échange de
dames et on voit si les dames s'échange
bien on arrive en finale
et vous savez que carson est très très
fort en finale et surtout dans cette
finale n'y a rien c'est symétrique 4
contre 4 1 contre 1 dans les files
asymétrique l'ont déjà quand c'est
symétrique c'est dur de gagner mais
alors si en plus c'est une finale
symétrique c'est quasiment impossible
on l'avait cas de liquidation il va y
avoir des échanges en pagaille et donc
ça simplifie on va rentrer en finale lan
on continue comme un retour ces hommes
protègent la dame qui entreprend à 3
puis on prend à 3 et la carson se résout
à un échange les dames tout reprend et
la jolie coûte carsen tranquille
regardez c'est subtil mais ça suffit
enfin c'est pas subtil c'est joli simple
cavaliers hausse est pourquoi bas et je
fais jouer le fou voilà ce foot actifs
ils contrôlent maintenant la diagonale
est alors que comme un cas était de vols
contrôlés rien et en plus sur protège la
casse s'est vite et j'ai envie de
contester cette tourner cette tour peut
pas vraiment se balader sur la société
on peut se balader sur cette rangée avec
la tour mais y'a pas d'endroits où on
peut aller on peut aller à 5 ce ça fait
un tout petit peu de pression sur 1,6
mais bon détroit pour attaquer à 6 c'est
comme faiblard moi jouer tour des six
avec les noirs en surprotège
on va doubler les tours sur la colonne
des ça marche pas donc rien donc la tour
fcm pour un an
il double les tours sur la colonne c'est
bon c'est la colonne où il est il a un
petit avantage
alors on garde quand même sur kallos est
si les noirs si les blancs avaient joué
un coup comme ici pour ses sets c'était
envisageable tout c'est cette attaque le
fou et le cavalier sept corps effet les
noirs alors très probablement il aurait
peut-être sans doute pas pris le
cavalier ici parce que le foot quand
même un peu supérieure en finale un
cavalier parce qu'ils y arrivent à viser
des deux côtés donc il aurait sans doute
pas fait ça mais il pouvait envisager
soit un coût assez simple de type fou c6
ou bien même fou des 5 parce que le
dessin que ce fou est quasiment
indélogeable protégé par le pion le 6 ou
alors ça obligerait les blancs a poussé
le pian 4 bon ok c'est possible aussi
vous sait s'ils sont nés contrôle est
bon sa maison qu'il n'y a pas vraiment
de vraies menaces sur la 7ème parce que
là les bleus arriveront pas vraiment à
doubler quoi on va protéger quand même
mais on aurait pu quand même jouer ça il
ne choisit pas ça il a fait tous rêver
c'est un tour ses huit propositions en
échange de tours bon là on voit que ça y
est il ya plus grand chose à espérer du
côté blanc fou des trois bons le fou se
met sur une belle case où il tape sur un
petit peu sur pion à 6 oblige le fourbe
et 7 à rester sage tour des huit
attaques le fou c'est en vain que la
tour c 8 est protégé par le fouet par le
cavalier le foot est roi est
effectivement attaqué tôt prend tout
reprendre et qu'elle allait prendre un
an de ce qu'on tente apparemment de la
nulle calais d2 bon il peut venir en b3
et en c5 attaque le foot à cassis donc
il faut juste faire attention à ça pas
de problème pour car c'est nier at on vu
bien sûr cavaliers regarder b6 est
maintenant sur ko libé trois menaces que
les c5 simplement calais 17
voilà je protège la casse et celles non
y'a plus qu'à glisser 5
je peux encore le maître en a 5 mai à 5
s'attaque pas à six il suffit de pousser
vite oui c'est très solide même si le
pion est un peu attaquées par le four on
peut pas difficile de rajouter de la
tacc avec lecavalier
d'autant que le pion à 3 peut s'avérer
fait mais aussi les noirs peuvent se
jouer aussi calé c5 qui attaquent le
fouet surprotège à six et à prendre mais
l'heure au centre c'est un peu ce qui va
se passer
roy f1 aura et fuite 31.7 roi des 2 3
des 6 3 c3 regardé comme en finale
une fois que les pièces en sont au
maximum de leurs possibilités
surtout on affaiblit pas ses pions comme
ça sans réfléchir mais on regarde et on
centralise les rois des rois deviennent
des pièces d'attac en finale puisqu'ils
ne sont plus en menacent ils sont plus
menacés de maths donc leur force existe
c'est comme des pièces qui ont une
puissance sur l'échiquier un droit c'est
quand même des pièces qui contrôlent
beaucoup de cases moi c'est quand même
assez puissant
cabaye 5 attaques attention le fou on
l'a dit tout de suite tout à leur
attention fouet un peu supérieure un
cavalier donc il faut faire attention il
faut deux rois ces cinq oppositions des
rois empêche le roi blanc d'aller plus
loin dans l'échiquier f4 à noter ici un
conjoint n'a pas peur de jouer les
espions comme ça parce qu'on est sur
noir le fou et en surface blanche
qu'elle et ses six propositions des
changes
mais là ne veut pas continuer c'est une
position vraiment équilibré un bon
cavalier prend ra prend roi des quatre
centralisation ça peut faire un peu peur
mais n'ont pas de problème f6 pourquoi
est ce si ce pas parce que les noirs tôt
ou tard vont vouloir jouer six ans mais
elle peut encore une fois sur noir comme
ça le fou peut pas les attaquer on a une
petite faiblesse en a 6 mai est bon à
tout moment on peut jouer à 5 l'ain
à noter que si les blancs jouent à 4
bonjour et a5 avec les noirs ont le
bloquerai sur l'a4 ce pion parce
qu'étant surclasse blanche ce serait une
cible pour le fou et demi alors que ça
serait plus qu'une défense à faire pour
les blancs voilà il difficile attaquer
les pions sur noir il faut mettre l'eau
fois les chars faut y aller avec le roi
alors que le fou les fous peuvent
attaquer les pions sur blanc pour sa
regarder que les deux camps évite
d'avoir trop de plans sur blanc et non
en nombre de et les blancs non seulement
j'ai deux pions plus à tout moment il
peut venir angers 3e 4 maintenant pour
les blancs voire 10 mai se cassent
blanche mais les noirs peuvent pas
bloquer et on joue en 5 puisqu'il serait
perdue le pion donc en fait on joue 1,4
pour venir à 1,5
voilà on joue en 4 en transition mais on
veut bien aller sur une case noire voilà
c'est pas contradictoire est ce que
génial donc l'art wade si c'est
maintenant à eux cinq échecs
proposition 2 nuls manade sicard s'est
nourri sans doute poursuivi par pions
prend 1,5 et puis après
pion prend 1,5 de rejouer sans doute
beaucoup que le roi c6 pour éviter que
laurent blanc puisse avancer plus est
sur un coup comme fou h trois échecs
simplement web et 5 voilà on est cinq à
l'attaqué le pion à 3 ce cas-là bon on
va protéger
on va jouer ici il faut bien obligés
d'aller en protection pour empêcher le
roi regarder il peut pas bouger ce roi
et sur noir donc le fou peut pas
l'attaquer ce fou donc empêche
globalement de bouger on s'est mis en
défense pour rien voilà donc c'est pour
montrer que voilà il n'y a pas de rien à
faire dans cette position
la feria seule faiblesse noir c'est le
pion aux risques évités vissé à 6 et une
fausse faiblesse puisque à tout moment
on peut jouer à 5
une seule faiblesse suffit pas voilà peu
m en fous à l'attack mais s'est défendu
on peut pas passer avec le repreneur
faut juste empêcher que laurent blanc
puisse en très bien quand il suffit de
se mettre en opposition
voilà donc les deux joueurs qu'on vienne
du nul après ascend anand 40 et un coût
évidemment c'est pas pareil que les 122
coup de la 7e donc c'est une partie
assez courtes où on n'a pas vraiment
cherché les variantes les plus les plus
tendues il a joué très solide il a
menacé m tout petit peu de bon sens sans
créer de vrais problèmes à carsen voilà
donc c'est peut-être une occasion perdue
pour un an mais bon il ya jours de repos
maintenant et peut-être qu'un an de va
maintenant préparer quelque chose en vue
des quatre dernières parties se préparer
à essayer de remonter au score
c'est essentiel voilà merci de m'avoir
suivi pour cette huitième partie du
match à nantes car scène une partie sans
doute de transition qu'on n'oubliera
s'est vite loin de la 7e un petit petit
juste rappel du score ici voilà donc la
dernière partie ici et nulle donc qu
arsène a gagné la deuxième il a gagné la
sixième qu'on a vu une partie qu'il
aurait pu perdre aussi
ça s'est joué un petit peu sur enfin ça
c'est pas jouer sur ce coup et moins
donné disons qu'il a fait une faute qui
aurait pu inverser le résultat
mais on ne l'a pas vu c'était pas dans
le cours de la partie
la victoire de carsen n'est pas n'est
pas illogique c'est pas une il a quand
même dominé cette partie voilà donc ils
mènent continue à mener car ce n est
donc qu il aura de nouveau les blancs
dans la prochaine et le match continue
il reste qu'à parti pour un angle pour
tenter de revenir au score et pourquoi
pas rejoindre les tie breaks
merci de m'avoir suivi pour ce match
championnat du monde de cars scène à
nantes et à bientôt sur diagonale tv
ciao